[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
يارب
[موسيقى]
ورغم ما تؤكده تركيا والامم المتحده من
تضرر الطرق الواصله الى معبر باب الهوى
الا ان وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه رصدت عمل
المعبر بشكل طبيعي لكن ليس لنقل المساعدات
وانما لنقل جثث السوريين الذين قتلوا بسبب
الزلزال في تركيا والان يعودون ليتم دفنهم
في سوريا وطلب سوريون عند المعبر تركيا
بضروره فتح المعابر بسبب الكارثه الحاليه
الاصح ان كل الطرقات صالحه
منذ اليوم الاول للزلزال وحتى تاريخ اليوم
نحن خلال ثلاثه ايام المعدن مفتوح فقط
امام استقبال الجنازات السوريين
الذين لهم يقيمون لاجئين في الاراضي
التركيه
السوريين السيارات تنقلهم من عده ولايات
الى ماذا بالهوى
الى دفهم في المناطق المحرره شمال غرب
سوريا
والله انتظر عائله كامله هلا جايين على
الطريق
وصلنا يومين عم يستنى هلا اليوم خبرونه من
تحت الانقاذ وهلا جايبينو على الطريق
جايين
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان حجم
الخسائر في الارواح جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا صادم ومروع حقا وذكر ان
الولايات المتحده نشرت اكثر من 150 من
عناصر البحث والانقاذ في تركيا وان واشنطن
ستكون لديها المزيد لتعلنه في الايام
المقبله بشان الكيفيه التي ستواصل بها دعم
الشعبين التركي والسوري خلال مرحله
التعافي من الدمر
وتنضم الينا من واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي
مراسله العربيه وايضا من ازمارين الصحه في
محمد الاشقر اهلا بكما ابدا معك ناديه
يعني بلينكن يتحدث بانه لدى الولايات
المتحده المزيد لتعلنه
بالقادم من الايام فيما يخص المساعدات عن
اي مساعدات بالتحديد يتحدث يعني هل هنالك
من معلومات حول ما ستتضمنه التواريخ
هو يتحدث عن مساعدات لتركيا والى سوريا
وهناك بالفعل تفاصيل اولا
اعلن عن طبعا نقل حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه يو اس اس جورج اتش بوش الى
الشواطئ التركيه القرب من الشواطئ التركيه
مساعدات اضافيه يعني هناك ايضا الوجود
العسكري الامريكي الذي سيساهم في العاده
عندما تكون هناك كوارث يتم بالفعل توظيف
الجنود والعمل على
انقاذ
الموجودين تحت الانقاض او في مناطق سواء
كانت زلزال او فيضانات او غيرها لكن عدا
عن ما قاله طبعا وزير
الثالث اليومي تقريبا للاداره الامريكيه
التي ترى بان هذا الزلزال المدمر من خلال
هذه الصور المؤثره جدا ترى بانه يجب علي
ان تتحرك وان تتحرك
من وزاره الخارجيه الى وكاله التنميه
الامريكيه usa بان تقود جهود الولايات
المتحده اولا في تركيا وثانيا في سوريا
ليست بهذه الاولويه طبعا لكن طبعا بالنسبه
لتركيا معروف بان هناك فرق انقاذ امريكيه
تذهب الى هناك فرق
لكن بسوء بسوريا بالتحديد قبل قليل ايضا
قالت
انها لن تستثني اي من السوريين المتاثرين
بالزلزال من المساعدات الامريكيه وهنا
اشاره الى اللقط الذي كنا نتحدث عنه قبل
يومين تقريبا عن هل ستصل الى المناطق التي
سيسيطر عليها النظام اقصد المساعدات يبدو
بالفعل بان المساعدات الامريكيه ستصل الى
الجميع لكن المشكله الاساسيه كيفيه وصول
هذه المساعدات الى سوريا بسبب تعقيدات
المشهد هناك سواء كان سياسي سواء كان فتح
المعابر او حتى وجود ولكن المنظمات الغير
حكوميه العامله على الارض وقدره الولايات
المتحده العمل معها ولكن ناديه يعني لماذا
يعني ان كان هناك نيه بارسال هذه
المساعدات من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بالضغط على تركيا ربما لفتح اكثر من معبر
ليس فقط معبر باب الهوى
صحيح وهذا ما طلب به المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه تحدث هو عن مدخل او معبر باب
الهوى لكن هناك بالسلامه وغيرها من
المعابر التي يمكن بالفعل تفعيله وخصوصا
في وقت الازمات
نتحدث عن كارثه بهذا الحجم
فالولايات المتحده تضغط في الواقع هناك
اتصالات
مكوكيه تجري مع انقره ليس فقط لتقديم
المساعده لكن ايضا بالفعل للتاكد من هذه
المساعدات ستصل الى السوريين يعني
بالنهايه في تركيا او في منطقه هاتايا
التي ضربها الزلزال بالتحديد هناك دوله
ودوله صناعيه متقدمه الدوله حلف في شمال
الاطلسي لكن في سوريا المناطق التي ضرب
فيها الزلزال هي مناطق ريفيه تخضع لسيطره
المعارضه فيها مهجرين من الحرب الاولى بال
2010 حتى الان وبالتالي الخدمات معدومه
ومن هنا تاتي الطارئه يعني الفرق بين
الحياه
والموتات ليست اكثر وبالتالي هي الولايات
المتحده تدرك هذا لكن هي تقول بانها تحاول
باسرع وقت ان توصل هذه المساعدات ربما
الاليه هي التي تصعب وصولها ناديه
المساعد المساعدات الامريكيه التي ستصل او
تجمع هي ليست فقط من جهات رسميه امريكيه
انما ايضا من جهات
ومنظمات غير حكوميه الجيش الامريكي ايضا
له دور وهناك يعني تبرعات من المواطنين
الامريكيين
بالفعل اولا اريد ان اشير الى ما قالته لي
الخارجيه الامريكيه بان الولايات المتحده
هي الدوله الاولى في العالم المانحه
للمساعدات بالنسبه لسوريا طبعا هذه بدات
منذ بدايه الحرب في سوريا وطبعا تبعتها
عقوبات على نظام وغيرها لكن بالنسبه للشعب
الامريكي عاده هو يتعاطف مع الازمات بغض
النظر عن الوضع السياسي حتى عندما تكون
كوارث مثل الزلزال الذي نرى هناك تغطيه
مكثفه للاعلام الامريكي لما يحدث الان في
سوريا وفي تركيا بالفعل هناك تبرعات من
المواطنين عاديين يعني هناك جمعيات طبيه
جمعيه اغاثه سوريه امريكيه موجوده هنا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تقوم بجمع كل ما
يستطيع اي مواطن امريكي ان يتبرع به من
دولار واحد الى يعني الاف الدولارات الى
الملابس طبعا كما تعرفين الوضع هناك سيء
جدا بسبب الاحوال الجويه
القارصه بالنسبه بروده الجو بالنسبه
للثلوج الى اخره فهو مستعدون لاستقبال اي
من المساعدات العينيه لحليب الاطفال حتى
ملابس شتويه وغيرها وبالتالي هناك مراكز
في الولايات المتحده في واشنطن في ولايه
فرجينيا تقوم بجمع كل التبرعات للشعبين
السوري والتركي لكن لسوريا بالتحديد بسبب
سوء الوضع وطبعا عدم مقارنه مع دوله كما
ذكرت مثل تركيا لكن ايضا الجيش الامريكي
يقوم بنشر او باقامه جسور جويه لارسال كل
هذه المساعدات عبر طائرات خاصه تنقل ما
تستطيع طبعا باكبر كميات حتى تصل الى
المتضررين وباسرع وقت ممكن ناديه ونحن
نتحدث نشاهد هذه الصور من عزمارين بريف
ادلب طبعا جهود
للجرافات والاليات الثقيله نشاهد جرافه
كبيره تحاول انتشال عائله كان تحدث عنها
مراسلنا من هناك
محمد هل تسمعني
نعم اسمعك طيب محمد حدثنا عن جهود وعمليه
البحث التي نراها في هذه الصور المباشره
يعني هل سمعت اصوات لاحياء كنت تحدثت
برساله سابقه كما ذكرت عن عائله
نعم يعني في الحقيقه كما تشاهدون الان
تحاول فرق الدفاع المدني
اخراج جثمان امراه ظهرت امامهم للاسف هذه
الامراه هي متوفيه ويستمرون في البحث عن
عن طفلها بحسب شهود عيان هذا الجزء الذي
وجدت به فرق الدفاع المدني هذه الامراه
انهم يبحثون ايضا عن طفلها وهو على الاغلب
بجانبها طبعا للاسف
هذه هذا الجثمان هو الامراه متوفيه وعلى
الاغلب ان ابنها ايضا قد تعرض للوفاه الى
حد هذه اللحظه لما يتمكن احد من تحديد
وجود احد لا يزال الى حد هذه اللحظه حيا
العمليات البحث لا تز
مستمره بشكل جماعي من قبل فرق الدفاع
المدني والاهالي الذين اتوا الى هنا الى
هذه المنطقه طبعا الجميع يترقب بحاله حذر
وترقب هنا خروج اي احد حي من تحت هذه
الاوقات بعد هذه الساعات الطويله على مرور
على حدوث الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب المنطقه
طبعا يعني
الصوره هنا
ماساويه جدا حاله رجال هنا تبكي يعني ذوي
الضحايا كل احد تمكنت سرق الانقاذ من
انتشال احد يخصه من تحت الارض ينهى باكيا
الجميع هنا الان في حاله ترقب وحذر ان ان
راقدنا حاله رقب الاهالي تحت وحديثهم مع
فرق الدفاع المدني وطلب منهم البحث في
اماكن محدده من هذا المبنى
المدمر بشكل كامل يعني في الحقيقه نحن هنا
في شمال غرب سوريا نعيش كارثه حقيقيه بكل
ما تعنيه الكلمه كارثه كبيره تفوق قدرات
الفرق الانقاذ وفرق الدفاع المدني
والناشطين المتواجدين هنا والتي لا يعملون
اساسا باعلى من طاقاتهم طبعا
يعني محمد تتحدث
الصوره تتحدث
يعملون في الجزء العلوي من المبنى
لانتشال جثمان الامراه المتوفيه التي ظهرت
امامهم للاسف محمد ابقى معي ونحن نشاهد
هذه الصور المباشره لمحاوله انقاذ واخراج
المراه التي تحدثت عنها وهي متوفيه ويستمر
البحث عن طفلها كما ذكرت واعود اليك ناديه
يعني تحدثتي عن تغطيه مكثفه للاعلام
الامريكي لهذا الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا
وتركيا هل يغلب اغاثه المنكوبين تحديدا
بسوريا على الاعتبارات
السياسيه ويضعها جانبا
نعم هو يغطي معظم الاعلام الامريكي يغطي
الزلزال
ككارثه انسانيه بالدرجه الاولى لا احد
يتحدث عن اعتبارات سياسيه
هناك بالفعل تعاطف كبير جدا ومن لا يستطيع
ان يتعاطف مع هذه الصور المؤثره مع هذا
الدمار الكبير
معهد الصدمه التي حدثت بالفعل لكل من يرى
ما يحدث على شاشات التلفزه وبالتالي اعتقد
بان التركيز من كل الطواقم الاعلاميه
الامريكيه هو على الوضع الانساني تماما
يعني نشاهد كما نرى على شاشه العربيه بانه
هناك وصف لانقاذ بعض الاشخاص لام تنتظر
ربما طفلها لا يزال على قيد الحياه
محاوله بالفعل مرافقه فرق الانقاذ والبحث
حتى ربما يكون خبر مفرح نحن نتحدث عن
ثلاثه ايام ربما اكثر بعد حدوث الزلزال
وبالتالي ربما الامل بدا يتلاشى نوعا ما
لكن اعتقد بانه التركيز الاعلامي الامريكي
هو ايضا اثر في مراكز القرار ومنها
الكونغرس الكونجرس قبل قليل عدد من اعضاء
الكونجرس قالوا بانهم بالفعل يريدون ان
يرسلوا كل هذه المساعدات لسوريا لكن طبعا
الجانب السياسي هو عدم التطبيع مع نظام
يفصلون هذه القضيه تماما عن تقديم مساعدات
انسانيه للمتضررين بسبب الزلزال في سوريا
شكرا جزيلا لك ناديه البلبيسي على هذه
المعلومات مراسله العربيه من واشنطن
واتابع معك من
عزمارين بادلب تحديدا الصحه في محمد
الاشقر محمد يعني
هذه الصور التي نراها مثل ما ذكرنا هي
محاولات لانقاذ العالقين تحت الانقاذ في
ريف ادلب منذ ثلاثه ايام هذا المبنى كم
طابق يحتوي هل هنالك من عدد تقريبي للسكان
الذين كانوا فيه
هل تسمعني محمد نعم يعني في الحقيقه هذا
المبنى نعم هذا المبنى الظاهر امامكم كان
يحتوي على سبعه
طوابق كل طابق يحتوي على على منزلين لا
تزال الى احد هذه اللحظه فرق الانقاذ
العمل بحثا عن الناجين او يحاولون انتشال
جثامين الضحايا الذين توفوا نتيجه مرور
هذا الوقت
كله طبعا هذا التاخر في انتشال الضحايا هو
بسبب ضعف الامكانيات الصوره واضحه امامكم
فرق الانقاذ التابعه للدفاع المدني او حتى
للاهالي يعملون بادوات بسيطه بادوات
يدويه يعني لا تساعدهم كثيرا في انتشال
الضحايا الان هم ما لهمش في الجزء العلوي
من هذا المبنى المدمر لا يزالون يحاولون
اخراج جثمان امراه ظهرت امامهم وهي متوفيه
وايضا يبحثون عن طفلها بحسب شهود العيان
الذين طلبوا منهم البحث في هذا الجزء ايضا
عنا طفل هذه الامراه التي ظهرت امامهم
طبعا كما تشاهدون منذ وقت وقت وقت مضي على
محاولتهم لاخراج هذه الامراه هذا الوقت هو
بسبب انعدام الامكانيات انعدام التجهيزات
المجهزه للتعامل مع مثل هذه الكوارث الوقت
الطويل يتسبب بارتفاع اعداد الوفيات وقله
اعداد الناجين في مبنى مجاور لهذا المبنى
تحدث لنا شهود عيان عن عن انتشالهم ل75
جثمان لحالات وفيات بينما تمكنوا من انقاذ
جريحين مصابين فقط وقسوا على هذه النسبه
بالنسبه لجميع المباني نحن نتحدث عن مئات
المباني التي التي
تهدمت بشكل كامل في شمال غرب سوريا نحن
نتحدث عن اكثر من 56
قريه وبلده ومدينه تعرضت للاضرار كان اكثر
الاضرار في مدينه
جنديرس في ريف مدينه عفرين هذه المدينه
المنكوبه هذه المدينه التي سقطت فيها
وتدمرت فيها
عشرات المباني بشكل كامل في حين ان
المباني التي لم تتدمر بشكل كامل هي غير
صالحه للسكن بسبب الدمار الجزئي التي الذي
حدث بها ايضا نحن نتحدث عن منطقه بثانيه
وسقوط حي
على سوريا بالارض نتيجه
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب المنطقه
التي نحن متواجدون فيها نحن نتحدث ايضا عن
مدينه ارمناز عن بلده ملس ان محمد لا
يسمعني التي تستمر فرق الدفاع المدني في
انقاذ الضحايا وانتشال الضحايا من تحت
الارقام اذا نشاهد بهذه الصور مثل ما ذكرت
محمد اعداد كبيره من عمال الانقاذ الذين
يحاولون مثل ما ذكرت اخراج امراه وطفلها
من تحت هذا المبنى الذي نراه مهدما يعني
عمليات البحث
مستمره ان كان بسوريا او تركيا جهود كبيره
والكلمات طبعا لا تصف ماساه السوريين
الذين عانوا اصلا من عقد من الزمان بسبب
الحرب ولكن يعني بين ساعه واخرى ان كان
بسوريا او تركيا يعني تحدث بعض المعجزات
وبصيص الامل يبقى مع اخراج احياء ان كانوا
اطفالا ام كبارا وسط يعني اعداد كبرى من
الاموات والضحايا للاسف ينضم الي ايضا من
ادلب مسلم السيد عيسى عبر سكايب الصحفي
اذا مسلم السيد عيسى السيد مسلم يعني
الوضع بادلب منذ قليل علمنا عن انه الهزه
الارضيه التي
حصلت منذ ساعه تقريبا
ادت الى انهيار مبنى بمدينه حرستا بريف
دمشق ماذا عن الوضع حيث تتواجد انت
الحقيقه الهزات الارتداديه لم تتوقف منذ
وقوع الزلزال بحسب اداره الكوارث التركيه
التي تحدثت عن مئات الهزات الارتداديه قبل
دقائق ايضا هناك كانت هزات اعداديه شعرنا
هنا بها في مدينه ادلب وعموم مناطق شمال
وغرب سوريا
وايضا هناك خبر عاجل عن ازدياد اخر
احصائيه للدفاع المدني اعلن عنها قبل
دقائق من الان ان عدد الضحايا في شمال غرب
سوريا فقط فاقه 1780 قتيلا هم فقط من
انتشلوا من بين الانقاض وتم اخراجهم الى
مناطق امنه هناك مئات العوائل الاخرى التي
لا تزال عالقه داخل هذه الابنيه المهدمه
نتحدث فقط يعني في هذه الاثناء الدفاع
المدني وفرق الانقاذ لا تزال تعمل في خمسه
عشر نقطه
فقط في النقاط شمال وشمال غرب محافظه ادلب
وايضا في بلده جنديرس والاتارب وترمانين
هذه المناطق هي حقيقه تعيش نكبه بكل ما
تعنيه الكلمه قبل ساعه من الان وصلنا الى
مدينه ادلب على طول الطرقات الممتده بين
مدينه ادلب والحدود السوريه التركيه هناك
الاف العوائل تفترش الطرقات الساحات
العامه نتيجه الخوف والهلع من اي ردات
اهتزازيه للزلزال الاساسي وايضا نتيجه
التدمير الذي حصل فيه العائلات سيد مسلم
يعني من يعتني فيها هي تفترس الارض ليس
هنالك اي من اي جهات ان كان حكوميه او غير
يعني جهات غير حكوميه غير سوريه يعني تقدم
لها الطعام او ربما التدفئه
حتى هذه اللحظه لم نوثق وجود ايمن منظمات
دوليه او ربما فرق انقاذ جاءت من خارج
الحدود ما يعمل على الارض حتى هذه اللحظه
هم رجال الانقاذ وفرق الدفاع المدني
والمؤسسات والمنظمات المحليه وايضا المئات
من الشبان المتطوعين من ابناء المناطق
هناك نقطه جدا مهمه يجب علينا توضيحها
لماذا الان المنظمات الانسانيه وفرق
الانقاذ عاجزه عن تقديم المساعدات الطارئه
قبل ساعات قليله فقط من وقوع الزلزال كانت
المنظمات الانسانيه قد افرغت 90% من
محتويات مستودعاتها الاغاثيه لاغاثه من
تضرروا بفعل كارثه الشتاء التي ضربت
المخيمات الثلوج التي ضربت اكثر من 500
مخيم في مناطق شمال وشمال غرب سوريا
فبالتالي
المنظمات الانسانيه اليوم عاجزه ليس لديها
اي من الامكانيات المحليه افرغت
مستودعاتها قبل ساعات من هذه الكارثه
تنتظر مدها بالشاحنات الاغاثيه المواد
العاجله الليئه توضيح اكثر
عبرت عنه المنظمات الانسانيه هنا في
الداخل اكثر ما يلزم الان هو الاشياء
الطارئه من الغذاء السريع من الوجبات
الساخنه لهؤلاء العوائل الذين تركوا كل
شيء خلفهم وايضا نقطه مهمه جدا وشاهدتها
بعيني للعوائل المنتشره اغلب الاطفال
الذين هم الان في الطرقات لا يملكون
الالبسه الشتويه من قبعات وقفازات وغيرها
الان انا داخل المنزل ويعني البس الستره
السميكه ربما درجات الحراره الان قاربت
على صفر في هذه المنطقه
حسب ما ذكرت يفترشون العراء اذا اهم
الاشياء
هم بحاجه لها الغذاء الوجبات الساخنه
والثياب الشتويه
للاطفال حسب ما ذكرت مسلم يعني طيب اخبرنا
اكثر عن نقاط الايواء الموجوده نقاط
اللواء المؤقته هل هنالك من خيم او مخيمات
نصبت
هناك يعني استقبال هؤلاء لو بشكل مؤقت
كل ما تم انشاؤه حتى اللحظه هو داخل
الاماكن المفتوحه في مساجد وفي المدارس
وفي الاماكن الاماكن التي هي امنه نسبيا
اكثر من المنازل والبيوت الطابقيه لكن
الجدير بالذكر هناك نقطه مهمه شاهدناها في
حارم وفي سلقين وغيرها الاهالي والتي قدمت
لها الخيام كاغاثه عاجله لتنتقل الى مناطق
امنه نصبت هذه الخيام بالقرب تماما من
نقاط التي دمرت فيها منازلها اولا
للانتظار لخروج احب واقاربهم من تحت
الانقاض وقالوا انهم لا يريدون الابتعاد
عن منازلهم التي سويت بالارض هي حقيقه
الاهالي هنا يعني اصبحت متمسكه بالارض
لانها نزحت عشرات المرات 12 سنه وبالتالي
هي لا تستطيع النزوح وايضا لا يوجد اماكن
ربما تستوعب هؤلاء النازحين نتحدث عن اكثر
من عشرين الف الى ثلاثين الف شخص هم فقط
بدون ماوى الان
مشردون على الطرقات لكن العدد مرجح
للزياده بشكل اكبر من ذلك بكثير مع
الماساه اكثر وازدياد يعني وضوح الصوره
اكثر وانتشار المزيد من الضحايا من بين
الانقاذ ابقا معي من ادلب الصحفيه مسلم
السيد عيسى
يشهد الطريق الواصل الى بلده الاصلاحيه
المنكوبه في غازي عنتاب جنوب تركيا اضرارا
بفعل الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه فيما
السلطات تكثف جهودها لفتح هذا الطريق
الرئيسي الى البلده تتواصل ايضا من ناحيه
اخرى قوافل المساعدات والاغاثه التي
تقدمها عبر طريق بديله الى الاصلاحيه
نحن الان في غازي عنتاب وكما تشاهدون من
خلفي هناك جسر انهار على طريق رئيسي يصل
الى بلده الاصلاحيه وهي بلده منكوبه
ومتضرره جراء الزلزال وما زالت عمليات
الاغاثه والانقاذ متواصله هناك وكما
تشاهدون الان هناك طريق بديل لكنه سيء جدا
تحاول السيارات والمدنيين والمواطنين
وهيئه الكوارث والطوارئ العبور عبر هذا
الطريق ووصول هذه المساعدات الى بلده
الاصلاحيه رئيسه البلديه قالت بان الاضرار
كبيره وكبيره جدا في بلده الاصلاحيه والتي
يقطنها عشرات الالاف ما زالت عمليات
الانقاذ متواصله على قدم وساق وهم يعملون
في انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من العالقين تحت
الانقاض غساله العربيه غازي عنتاب
وينضم الينا من
الحدود السوريه التركيه خالد ابو المجد
الصحفي وايضا نتابع مع السيد مسلم السيد
عيسى اهلا بكم من جديد خالد يعني حدثنا عن
الوضع الان على الحدود يعني
الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه تتحدث
باكثر من تصريح صحفي عن انه الخارجيه
السوريه تؤكد ان دمشق منفتحه على تلقي
المساعدات وبالتالي ليس هنالك من مشكله
ولكن المشكله عندكم هي بتوزيع هذه
المساعدات ووصولها الى كل المناطق
المتضرره
نعم طبعا كما ذكرنا سابقا لم تصل اي من
المساعدات للمناطق الخارج عن سيطره القوات
النظام ويعتبر الاهالي هنا او يعني الجميع
يعتبر هنا بان تصريحات قوات النظام بانها
فتحت الطريق الحدود هي لمكاسب سياسيه لها
فقط وليست لمساعده المتضررين حقيقه من
الزلزال في شمال سوريا وهي مكسب سياسي لهم
بالنسبه لهم ليقولوا فكوا القيود العقوبات
الدوليه عنا وسنقوم بتقديم المساعدات
للشمال سوريا ومع ذلك ليست هناك اي
مصداقيه لكلام القوات النظام وهي لم تقدم
اي مساعدات وليس مامول صراحه من تقديم
المساعدات وكذلك الجميع ينتظر من مساعدات
امميه وعاجله ربما كل دقيقه تتاخر فيها
هذه المساعدات يموت فيها شخص او تموت فيها
عائله جديده وسبب جميع بان هناك اناس ما
يزال تحت الانقاض منذ اكثر من 72 ساعه
وحتى هذه اللحظات كانت الحظوظ اكثر ربما
لو وصلت الدفعات الامميه يوم البارحه او
حتى اليوم اليوم صباحا فرق الانقاذ سواء
في شمال سوريا او جنوب تركيا قاموا بانقاذ
عدد كبير من المدنيين من تحت الانقاذ لكن
الان اصبحت يعني النسب لانقاذ المدنيين
ربما نسب ضئيله بسبب بسبب طول الوقت وما
يزال الكثير من المدنيين ما يزالون تحت
الانقاذ ليس مامون صراحه ابدا والجميع
يعتبر بان قوات النظام من خلال هذه
التصريحات هي لمكاسب سياسيه فقط وحتى الان
لم تصل اي مساعدات من الحدود سوريا
التركيه للداخل السوري ابدا السيد مسلم
يعني ماذا عن الانترنت عن الطرقات وايضا
الهواتف في المناطق المتضرره بالشمال
السوري نتيجه هذا الزلزال يعني كيف يتواصل
الناس هل هنالك من امكانيات للتواصل عبر
الهواتف والانترنت
هل تسمعني
السؤال نعم تفضل يعني اسالك عن الانترنت
والطرقات والهواتف هل هي مقطوعه بشكل كامل
بالمناطق المتضرره ام
حركتها وتعمل بشكل طبيعي
هو بقيه كل الخدمات هذه مقطوعه قرابه 48
ساعه بدات مع صباح اليوم
خدمات الكهرباء والمياه وايضا الانترنت
بالعوده بشكل تدريجي الى عموم مناطق
الشمال السوري الاهالي بقيت هنا منقطعه
تماما كما حدث في الجنوب التركي عن العالم
الخارجي في اليوم الاول لكن بعدها بدات
الاوضاع بالتحسن بشكل تدريجي حتى هذه
اللحظه
سيد خالد يعني وصف لنا المنطقه حيث تتواجد
انت على الحدود السوريه التركيه يعني هل
من حركه كنت ذكرت سابقا انه لم تدخل اي
مساعدات الى جانب السوري من تركيا ولكن ما
الحركه الان
لا يوجد اي جديد للاسف والجميع يناشد
الجميع يقول للعالم نحن هنا يعني السوريين
منكوبين منذ سنوات لكن هذه اللحظات ربما
هي الاسعار لم يتم الاستجابه لهم ابدا
طبعا اريد ان انوه لموضوع بخصوص المعابر
بان اداره معبر باب الهوى اكدت وقبل دقائق
تواصلت مع اداره المعبر واكدوا بان المعبر
جاهز ومفتوح
وليست هناك مشاكل لاستقبال اي يعني الطريق
الرئيسيه التي كانت الامم المتحده تقول
بان الطريق الرئيسيه التي تسلكها الشاحنات
متضرره وبحاجه للاصلاح هل اصلح الطريق
بحسب اداره المعبر بان ليست هناك اي مشاكل
يعني في المعبر وتستطيع اي من فرق الانقاذ
القدومي المعبر والتاكد وكذلك ايضا من
ناحيه اخرى فلنفترض بان معبر باب الهوى
فيه مشاكل
اصدرت
الحكومه السوريه المؤقته التي هي مسؤوله
عن معبر باب السلام الحدودي ومعبر الراعي
الحدودي في شمال حلب اصدرت قبل دقائق ايضا
بيانا عبر مواصل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
واكدت فيه بان المعابر جاهزه لاستقبال اي
من المساعدات الامميه
وايمن الخدمات لكن صراحه حتى الان لم يصل
شيء بالنسبه للسوريين للعالقين تحت
الانقاض يعني
المعابر بحاجه الى
قرار سياسي لاعاده فتحه سيد مسلم وايضا
سيد خالد ابقوا معي سنذهب
لنشاهد هذا التقرير عن الاف الجرح الذين
سقطوا حتى الان في الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا اصابات
مختلفه اضافت اعباء كبيره على القطاعات
الصحيه في هذه المناطق التي كانت تعاني من
نقص في التمويل والمعدات الاصابات
بدرجاتها المتفاوته تنظي برفع حصيله قتل
الزلزال التي ناهزت الاثنا عشر الف شخص في
الدولتين معا
[موسيقى]
نستمع الان الى هذا التسجيل الصوتي لشخص
سوري عالق تحت الانقاد
[موسيقى]
الصبر يا رب الصبر بس والله بتوجع كتير لا
تحرك ايدك لا تحرك ايدك
حاول تسحبك كثير
[موسيقى]
ايضا الينا من اضنه زيدان مراسل العربيه
زيدان حيث تتواجد ما هي اخر التحديثات
بشان عمليات البحث والانقاذ
نعم راويه ساعات قليله وينتهي اليوم
الثالث لوقوع هذه الكارثه الكبيره التي
ضربت تركيا او جنوب تركيا على وجه التحديد
وشمال سوريا يوم ثالث سينقضي ربما الاعمال
بالعثور على ناجين تتضاءل لكن مع ذلك جهود
الانقاذ مستمره كما تشاهدين هنا في هذا
الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه في وسط مدينه اضنه
جنوب تركيا احدى المناطق التي ضربها
الزلزال
طبعا جهود الانقاذ ما تزال مستمره منذ
وقوع الزلزال وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تتوقف
فرق الانقاذ عن العمل لدقيقه واحده في
محاوله وسباق مع الزمن للعثور على ناجين
او ربما يعني بصيص امل في حال سماع اي
اصوات لمواصله الحفر وجلب تعزيزات اضافيه
كما حدث في هذا الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه
الان راويه وهو موقع لبناء مكون من 14
طابقا دمر بالكامل المباني المجاوره ثلاثه
مباني مجاوره ايضا مهدده بالانهيار فيها
تشققات وتصدعات يعني مع اي هزه ارتداديه
قويه نوعا ما يمكن ان تؤدي الى انهيارات
جزئيه او كليه ومع وفي ظل هذه الظروف
الخطيره يواصل عمال الانقاذ جهودهم دون
توقف يعني في هذا المبنى حتى الان بعض
عمال انقاذ اخب انهم يشكون او يرجحون ان
يكون تحت الركام او تحت الانقاض هناك
حوالي 80 شخص لا يعلمون بالضبط هل بعضهم
ما زال على قيد الحياه ام لا لكن في كل
تقريبا كل يعني كل نصف ساعه تقريبا يسود
صمت في عمق المكان تطفئ الاليات العملاقه
والمولدات الكهربائيه
ويطلب من الجميع الصمت واغلاق الهواتف حتى
وينصت الجميع الى عمان انقاذ وهم يحاولون
سماع اي صوت قد يصدر من تحت الركام
بانه هذه هي الطريقه المعتمده باغلب
المناطق التركيه خلال عمليات الانقاذ يعني
صمت ثم سماع لي الاصوات اليس هنالك من
اليات استشعار متطوره ام انه هذه الطريقه
التقليديه هي الائمن والاسلم
والاكثر دقه ربما
نعم راويه يعني يوم امس كانت يعني بحسب ما
شاهدناه يوم امس كانت هذه هي الطريقه
الوحيده لكن اليوم كان هناك خبراء محليين
وايضا خبراء اجانب وصلوا الى الموقع كلا
الطرفين الفريق المحلي والفريق الاجنبي
لديه اجهزه متطوره وكلاب مدربه كانت تمشط
الموقع لكن مع ذلك مع ذلك هذه الطريقه
تستخدم بشكل دائم يعني يحاولون استخدام كل
الطرق التقليديه وغير التقليدات والمتطوره
في محاولات للعثور على ناجين يعني
ظهر هذا اليوم وبعد عمليه بحث للكلاب
المدربه وبعد دخول فريق اجنبي
رصد المكان باجهزه متطوره تم رصد
حركه او استشعار لوجود
ربما اشخاص عالقين على عمق اثنين فاصله
اربعه الى اثنين فاصله ثمانيه كما اخبرنا
عمال الانقاذ الذي كان في الموقع وبالتالي
تم توجيه فرق الانقاذ للحفر في تلك
المواقع لكن حتى الان لم يتم الوصول الى
نتيجه يعني العمليه معقده ليست بهذه بهذه
السهوله راويه لان اليات الحفر عندما
النقاط التي تشتبه بها الفرق الانقاذ
بوجود اشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاض في تلك
النقاط لا يتم استخدام اي اليات حفر
عملاقه انما اليات بسيطه خوفا من انهيار
انهيارات قد تؤدي الى هذه النهايات الى
سقوط ركام جديد في قرب الاشخاص الذين
يحاولون الوصول اليهم زيدان يعني ونحن شهد
هذه الصور كامله العربيه تنصب لنا
عمليه البحث بهذا المبنى عن ناجين دعنا
نذكر من جديد كم شخص متوقع او يمكن ان
يكون بهذا المبنى وهل يعني يسمع هؤلاء بين
الحين والاخر ربما اصوات او يعني نبضات
لاشخاص احياء ربما هل هنالك من امل تحديدا
بهذا الموقع الذي تتواجد فيه
نعم كما ذكرت قبل قليل لا يوجد معلومات
اكيده وارقام اكيده لكن من خلال فرق
الانقاذ من خلال ما سمعوه من الجوار
والمحيطين وتقدير عدد الاشخاص الذين كانوا
يقطنون هذا المبنى ومن خرج منهم حيا ومن
تم اجلؤه الى مناطق
ايواء يقدرون ان العدد تقريبيا ثمانين شخص
لكن هذا العدد ليس دقيقه مئه بالمئه لكن
يرجحون ان يكون هذا العدد هو تقريبي بجوار
بحدود 80 شخص لذلك جهود الانقاذ كثفت خلال
هذا اليوم يعني يوم امس كنا هنا ايضا في
هذا الموقع لمرتين
سمعت فرق الانقاذ اصوات من تحت الركام
واشتعل الموقع حقيقه يعني الليله الماضيه
فرحا بان هناك اشخاص ناجين لكن هذا اليوم
لم مره واحده تم سماع صوت او اصوات من تحت
الركام
ثم بعد ذلك كان هذا ظهر هذا اليوم بعد ذلك
لم يسمع اي صوت من تحت الركام ومع ذلك
يعني ربما فرق الانقاذ ترجح ان الحاله
الصحيه ربما مثلا قد تمنع في حال كان هناك
احد ما زال على قيد الحياه ربما الحاله
الصحيه قد منعته من اصدار اي صوت او اي
حركه لذلك الجهود تستمر
والاعداد التي وصلت الى هذا الموقع تضعفت
ما بين يوم امس وهذا اليوم سواء الاليات
العملاقه التي تمشط هذا المكان او تنظف
الركام بجوار الاماكن التي يجري البحث
عنها وكانها عمليه تنقيب حقيقه يعني ما
نشاهده الان
وبالتالي ايضا هناك اعداد اضافيه من
المتطوعين لذلك لانه هنالك اعداد اضافيه
من المتطوعين والتقنيين والاجهزه
المتطوره والاليات ارتفع عدد الضحايا من
الجانب التركي ارتفع ولكن اود ان اسالك عن
قرار ايقاف مثلا عمليه
البحث بمبنى ما كيف يؤخذ يعني على اي اساس
تتوقف الفرق ام لا لانه العدد عدد الايام
المصيريه لانقاذ اشخاص من تحت الدمار هو
بين خمسه الى سبعه ايام حسب البروتوكولات
نعم يعني غالبا يعني هنا في اضنه اتحدث عن
الولايه التي اوجدت فيها يعني بحسب ما
شاهدته لم يتم ايقاف العمل في اي موقع في
اي موقع لكن في بعض لكن في بعض المواقع
يتم توجيه اعداد اضافيه في حال استشعرت
فرق الانقاذ بوجود اعداد اضافيه او يجوز
اشتباه وجود ناجين لذلك يتم توجيه اعداد
اضافيه من المتطوعين الى هذا الموقع في
ولايات اخرى عندما يكون الدمار كبير جدا
يعني هذا يعني ما نقله لاحد الاشخاص
المتواجدين هناك مثلا في ولايات مثل هاتاي
او كهرمان مره عندما يكون مواقع الدمار
يعني هناك احياء كامله ردمت يتم توجيه
ايضا الكوادر من موقع الى اخر على حسب
الاشتباه بوجود اشخاص ناجين او لا
وبالتالي يعني
السلطات او فرق الانقاذ تتعامل على مبدا
في حال كانوا متاكدين ومتيقنين من ان
الموقع به مثلا فيه ناجين يتم تكثيف العمل
في اكثر من الموقع الذي الى هذه اللحظه لا
يوجد اي بوادر لوصول الى ناجي هذه هي
الاليات حاليا نتحدث عن دمار كبير هذا اول
للمره الاولى تتعامل تركيا مع هذا النوع
من الكوارث
راويه زلزال يضرب عشر ولايات يقطنها اكثر
من ثلاثه عشر مليون مساحات جغرافيه كبيره
جدا واحياء مدمره بالكامل تقريبا يعني في
مدينه انطاكيا مساحات واسعه جدا جدا ردمت
وايضا في مدينه غازي عنتاب في مثلا في
اصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب يعني هذه الامور هي
للمره الاولى تتعاطى معها الحكومه التركيه
بهذه الضخامه ابقى معي زيدان وابقي الصوره
لو سمحت وانتقل الى خالد ابو المجد من
الحدود التركيه السوريه السيد خالد يعني
الامم المتحده
تتحدث انه عن عمليات البحث والانقاذ لا
تغطي سوى بالمئه من المواقع المتضرره
بشمال السوري وبانها تعمل على تجهيز اول
قافله مساعدات للعبور الى
الشمال
وستنطلق هذه المساعدات غدا صباح غد صباح
الخميس
اذن اكدت بانه المعبر جاهز ماذا عن
الاليات او الجهات التي تتولى توزيع هذه
المساعدات او القوافل عندما تاتي من هي
نعم يوجد في الداخل السوري منطقتين يعني
كل منطقه لها اداره معينه في ريف حلب توجد
اداره ما يعرف الحكومه المؤقته وفي ادلب
ما يعرف باداره حكومه الانقاذ طبعا هاتين
الحكومتين على سابقا بانهم جاهزون لتقديم
العون لاي احد قادم من المعابر وكذلك من
يقوم بعمليه الاجلاء وربما هم من يقود هذه
خليه العمل اليوم هم قوات الدفاع المدني
التي تقوم بانتشال عدد كبير هم اصحاب
المعدات ولهم ايادي بيضاء في انتشار
الاعداد كبير من المدنيين من العالقين تحت
الانقاض وكذلك من المتوقع ان يتم التنسيق
فيما بينهم ان دخل احد الجميع يعني يطلب
دخول المساعدات امميه او خبراء باقصى وقت
ممكن النسبه ربما يعني هي قليله بنسبه 5%
لكن يعني ليست هناك نسبه محدده لكن هناك
عدد كبيره المواقع حتى الان يعني تحاول
فرق الدفاع المدني للوصول اليها ومن لم
تستطع فرق الدفاع المدني للوصول اليها
هناك اعداد كبيره من المدنيين قاموا بجلب
الياتهم واستقدامها من كل المناطق الخاضع
سيطرت المعارضه في كل المناطق كالاليات
الثقيله
كالروافعكسات والوسادات الهوائيه
المتواجده عند الدفاع المدني كذلك حاولوا
الانتشار على اكبر عدد من المواقع لكن لم
تغطى كل المواقع يعني ما حصل في تركيا وما
حصل الان في سوريا حتى تركيا الدوله
المجهزه هناك مساعدات امميه قدمت اليها
وربما استخدم زياده لتلافي هذه الكارثه في
منطقه هي بالاساس لا توجد فيها بنيه تحتيه
المعيشيه وليست بنيه تحتيه لتفادي الازمات
لكن الخبرات عند الدفاع المدني في الاجلاء
المدنيين خلال عشر سنوات كانت كفيله
لانقاذ عدد كبير من المدنيين واي اي وفود
ربما تقدم الى المنطقه ستكون هناك فرق ذو
خبره من الدفاع المدني تقوم بمساعدتهم لكن
الدفاع المدني وحده لا يستطيع رغم كل
الجهود
او
في متوازيات متواجده بالدفاع المدني هي
بحاجه
لمساعدات ومعدات اخرى لانتشال اكبر عدد
السيد مسلم السيد عيسى يعني حدثنا عن
الطاقه الاستعابيه للمستشفيات
بمناطق مناطق المتضرره
بالشمال السوري ما النواقص يعني ما الذي
رصدت ربما ان كان من معلومات متوفره او من
اي شيء
في الحقيقه يعني التعامل كان مع هذه
الكارثه مختلف عن الحالات السابقه التي
تعيشها هنا المناطق نتيجه القصف وغيرها
اما حصل خلال ال 24 ساعه الاولى هو
استنفار في عموم المستشفيات والمراكز
الصحيه الموجوده في المنطقه
لطلقتها الاستيعابيه الكامله حقيقه دخلنا
الى اغلب المستشفيات المتواجده هنا خصوصا
في الاماكن الابعد عن مناطق الزلزال
الاساسي كانت المستشفيات ويعني ممراتها
ممتلئه بالجثث وايضا داخل غرف العمليات
وغرف الطوارئ الكثير من العمليات الطارئه
لانقاذ حياه من نجا ووصل الى المستشفيات
اكثر ما كان يلزم في هذه المستشفيات هو
الامور الطبيه الطارئه
للضمادات وغيرها لسد الاحتياج الاول ثم
الانتقال الى الجرحى والمصابين الاخرين
لكن خفت الان وتيره الجرحى الذين يصلون
الى المستشفيات في اليوم الثالث الذي
نعيشه اليوم وتقريبا انتهى هذا اليوم
نتيجه يعني انما يخرج الان هم اغلبهم من
جثث
المفقودين والقتله الذين قضوا لليوم
الثالث داخل او تحت هذه الانقاض لكن ضمن
سياق الامل ربما الاخبار التي
تاتي ضمن كل هذا الالم تم قبل دقائق من
الان انقاذ ثلاثه اشخاص في بلده جنديرس
رجل وامراه وطفل هم على قيد الحياه
بجروح متوسطه وبسيطه وبالتالي هناك يعني
مع كل حاله انقاذ
لعوائل وافراد على قيد الحياه يعود الامل
للعوائل والاشخاص الذين تجمعوا حول مناطق
الانقاذ نتحدث عن الاف الاشخاص كما ذكرت
في بدايه المداخله انهم فضلوا وضع خيامهم
بالقرب من
اماكن الانقاذ
بالقرب من الاماكن المدمره
للحفاظ على اقرب مسافه من ذويهم المفقودين
تحت هذه الابنيه وبالتالي مع كل خبر مفرح
يبقى هؤلاء الاهالي بالقرب من هذه الابنيه
على امل ان يعني تاتيهم اخبار مبشره
ومفرحه عن ذويهم المفقودين بعد انقضاء 72
ساعه على هذه الماساه
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من ادلب عبر سكايب
الصحفي مسلم السيد عيسى وايضا خالد ابو
المجد الصحفي من الحدود السوريه التركيه
ونتابع مع مراسلنا زيدان زنكلو من اضنه
وهذه الصور المباشره لاحدى عمليات انتشال
ان كان اشخاص قدوا تحت ركام منازلهم او
يمكن اشخاص لدينا امل بان يكونوا احياء
زيدان هل من تحديثات حول ان كان يعني هناك
بصيص امل ربما مثل ما ذكرنا باحد حي تحت
الركام بعد ثلاثه ايام على هذا الزلزال
نعم يعني راويه يعني بصيص الامل لدى
المسعفين او المنقذين ما يزال موجود يعني
اكثر من شخص تحدثنا اليه طوال هذا اليوم
كنا نسال يعني بعد هذه المده الطويله
والطقس البارد في حال كان هناك ناجين هل
سيصمدون امام هذه الظروف الجويه الصعبه
والبرد
دون ماء او طعام وشراب قالوا نحن نعمل
ونامل ان تتكلم جهودنا
بالنجاح والعثور وحتى لو كان كل هذا العمل
من اجل شخص واحد فقط فهو انجاز كبير لنا
ايضا في جوار هذا الموقع هناك العديد من
اقارب اشخاص مفقودين هنا او عالقين هنا او
اصدقائهم يعني هذا اليوم او قبل قليل
شهاده السيده كانت جالسه هنا قربه
قربه الموقع كانت تبكي تشاهد هذا وتبكي
ولا تريد ان تتحدث مع احد عندما يسود
الصمد كانت تتقدم اتجاه هذا الحاجز الذي
وضعته الشرطه كاخر نقطه يسمح للجميع
بالاقتراب اليها تسمع تحاول ان تسمع اي
نداء قد يخرج من فرق الانقاذ لتبشر الجميع
بوجود اشخاص ناجين او لا يعني هذا يعني
موقف حقيقه لا يمكن وصفه بالكلام ما
نشاهده هنا على ارض الواقع ابلغ من ذلك
بكثير مثلا شخص التقيته قبل قليل وتحدث
للعربيه قال انه قدم من منطقه جيبزا قرب
اسطنبول لان اقارب اقارب زوجته
والد زوجته هو والده زوجته هو شقيقات
زوجته الثلاثه جميعهم مدفونون هنا في هذا
المكان وهو رغم مضيف ثلاثه ايام ما زال
متفائل بان يخرج احياء وان تتمكن فرق
انقاذ من الوصول اليهم يعني مشاعر حقيقه
متناقضه ايضا صباح هذا اليوم شهاده شخص
قال ان ابن اخيه قد تم انتشار جثته من هذا
المبنى من تحت الركام يعني مشاعر ما بين
حسن
بعض الاهالي
ابقى معنا
زيدان زنكلو هذه الصور ولكن
التغطيه تغطيه العربيه تتواصل مع الزميله
ميسون شكرا